okay so it's been a week since our legs
went along so we're just going to get
right back into it this is a great
babysitter this was a it clearly is not
the case it's been we actually looked it
up I think it's been close to a year
since we did the last one and five years
yeah confession it's been five years is
my last everything universe Evan month
since my last confession it's uh we just
been busy and you know we started all
these other v-log like shows in the past
before we couldn't finish own because we
just kid we don't think these shows are
going to go that long and they just keep
going and going and it's like that's
great the good show now like my question
is why aren't you in the chair that's
behind you oh okay I'll rouse obsessed
yeah we're a whole no no be happy with
the verse no is your a zest with it cuz
does does bring the bitch air out is
like really not like are you really
gonna use this Sharik yeah I bought it
for reason I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
do this any fans out that it yes
yeah those always totally dated I don't
really know each air energy it's like
night janitor if it says great for my
baggage that exam ever pointed at it
this is what it would be like and then
almost is like oh no I I can't do this
like this
that's who cute that's like what do you
are Christmas little boy yeah that's the
only reason to set my goddamn chair okay
so what we're doing is you can pry tell
from the title of it is that because we
just don't have time to watch an episode
at a time and you know give our opinion
on them now especially because we are so
far behind and there's just a lines a
busy man we just got busy lies we're
working everything we're just going to
kind of do like we're going to try and
do with the coldest even bombs where
they drop like a big chunk of episodes
at a time to sort of go over those I'll
try to look up like which ones they
dropped at what times still don't know
how long it'll be in between we're gonna
try our best is to go a lot faster well
we just watched them in a row and and
we're just going to go through each
individual individual episode really
fast I just lost the list no
okay okay I can get back would have
happened if you were in the better
chance no it's one of happier than to
have me guard the goddamn chair okay
wasn't the 9b no amazing like he he like
sat down and like there wasn't even like
he didn't even think about it and I
cried I went out I put my hand over my
eyes I said oh my god I might wait God
was free yourself little boy we go
training in that actually that's my hat
no it was actually more embarrassing
yeah exactly
no you just said that he didn't even
like think about residuals immediate
sit-down just yeah this isn't gonna work
so it's like a little shorter like right
here a little sure I like here is that
be okay but like down here okay that bag
o ourn
so okay look at the goddamn beautiful
okay so we're frame with finishing out
the rest of this everything else will be
related following all be was Allison
these other things because we're walkin
of the Centaurs get have the following
all be sent I related all further
question that would be sent are related
okay so we have finish out season three
as well we're going to do here and the
last one we were on is alone at sea and
so we'll talk real fast about these uh
break the babysitter this was the one
where he goes don't worry after AV
sitter ever yeah not neither of them are
especially good he babysits sour cream
with rose quartz and yeah I like how
he's got like the baby has the voice of
Steven right yeah it's cute it's you
know it's just they're trying to only
ground have a throw up and up show he's
kind of a baby - he's even like in a
character the carousel at the end he
realizes he has to grow up the one thing
I really liked about it I thought it
stood out is every time to talk about
rose it's kind of like a Jesus set up
like oh he's perfect
yes I run with me wanting Rose Beale
powerful yeah I liked but once in a
while the more they do it the more kind
of shows a little bit more of like
gradual personality yeah
and it turns out she's a psycho bitch
you just totally let the baby walk in a
fair speck but I like how she shows the
best lines is that told you to watch er
I did or I told you to watch him I
didn't watch him I want him walk away
God it's going to be an experience where
before minutes expiry yeah it's going to
be fun and I I like my kind of shows the
flaws and the naivete and stuff like
that I like when she does seem a little
bit more human so and I felt like that
the most in this episode like demography
is defy but I like when she seems a
little bit more human especially when
she's brought a little bit more quirky
and expressive um so I dug anything you
got on it no honestly it was a fluffa
yeah pretty minor I'll give you the
usual standard aliens talking about
babies like they're not they're
different than you and I understand them
though you don't
what is one of those were like I saw a
third Rock from the Sun and I'm like
yeah I've seen this bit before yeah you
know um Jim Hunt this is one where
Connie goes with pearl and Steven
on a big hunt and they come across some
of these monsters gonna come across
Jasper Oh No
and she's collecting these gems um I
thought alone it's fine as a little doll
I thought Ozzy I'm trying to even
remember I just laughs I just liked it
for the pearl points I need to
incorporate for no no that that's the
next one oh that's correct okay this is
one where they're in winter and they're
hunting the the monsters and this is all
whenever walkie-talkies that she keeps
talking now it's kind of like the only
really like I like it just because I
thought it was fun to see them go on a
mission and I like this you know I like
I generated snow often I'm a pearl girl
so I I generally like episodes with
pearl but she was in a lot of it now
because she disappears and then it's
just them and yet you know what fuck
this episode this is any if I just and
do that much for me okay crack the whip
this is the one where someone had the
pearl points in it no that's the one
right after god damn it
Isabel barking good Jesus no this is the
one I did to learn discipline emphasis
comes across jazz burn so to Steven and
Connie uh and she gets knocked out this
time over they fuse yeah they fuse and
they take out Jasper I say get Connie
plus Steven coven just saying sure the
ight I forget did that fusion have a
name wasn't like Stefani or something
like that
I want them something like that Connie I
like coven better
it shows how long we've been away from
it uh I like that one I thought the
action was pretty cool I like anytime
there's a fusion I think it's cool I do
know that I particularly we'll get to
that later
yeah yeah well we'll definitely get to
that yeah um but uh yeah and you
definitely see a little bit of this
hostility building in her a little bit
business or starting a long kind of arc
with her which yes which is good but
this is mainly a this is mainly just
starting that off is this one today I
must get her butt kicked
yeah yeah that's started I know it's not
I'm going through this right now with
the flash which I'm watching on season
three MS licks and like Cisco's becoming
a bit of a bitch and like it I am NOT a
huge fan when they do that in series
it's ignore it er enough said and my
normal happy characters is going to be a
d-bag it's kind of it's like an episode
yeah maybe
especially for a kids show because kids
have a lot of pride and fathering my
level but it's like seemed like it was
drawn I don't feel kissing ah there was
something that always feels kind of like
when it's done not quite right it always
just feels arbitrary I'm like huh oh
that's not their normal personality so
they're just acting like a d-bag now
that just doesn't feel natural or right
I felt like okay if you can alot feel
like amethyst is a little better but
it's still just a plot point of meta
yeah there's those plot points you hate
this is one those I hate it's like I'm
not being able to character you're a fan
of now you're gonna hate me for a few
episodes and with why if they if they
made it into combine like this episode
with the one where they go to you know
the kindergarten where where uh Jasper
came from and that would have been okay
injustice because that's not a math
lesson but when you draw it out yeah not
as long what's the flash our hour-long
episode so that's really getting on my
nerves but it's not as long so it's okay
here but it's just that my favorite
thing like yeah but I think the episode
suck a lot of fine but then that brings
us to Steven versus amethyst which is
the low with pearl point yeah at the
Pearl pouch
I want to earn pearl points and I want
prizes from the Pearl pouch and I feel
like a feel like that was the best part
because again the rest of it is you
already know what they're going to learn
at the end you already know the lessons
going to be I think even kids kind of
figure it out and so when they're having
that great big long side it's kind of
like yeah yeah that's where you suck at
losing yeah I mean the setup was kind of
funny they want to see who is worse you
know it has the competition to see who
sucks more so it's a little funny but
it's like hey like you just get this a
fight there is somebody you can
slapstick that was about in and then we
got a 22 minute episode called this damn
um okay that was a cheese by the way
because I thought are they all going to
be 22 minutes now because I would've
loved yeah like little commercial breaks
with like this must in it and stuff I
was just like so is that like on do
crystal gem how's the director saying
one of the episodes I remember most
because it's 22 minutes and I'm sorry I
just retain information better in a
22-minute format versus the 11 minute
format okay you know here's my question
uh because I'm watching it and you
already know something's up with again
this is the one where bismuth it was one
of the original crystal gems she's
trapped in the mane of the lion and they
find her and then you discover why she
was making these weapons they're
becoming a little in their world to
savage and you know one Adric destroys
gems and stones and stuff and Steven
essa has to put her back you know
doesn't destroy you ever puts her back
and finds out that's what Rose is
and hey Steven I got this great weapon
let's commit murder you know love is
like this get Derek it was very it was
very intensive no doctor I want to turn
shatter I'm like yeah it sounds rudl and
the way that feeling with sword the rock
of mannequin whatever you want calm
shattering yeah and just the way it goes
through and comes out it's like it looks
like man but this is fierce this is like
a it erupt - because I'm not entirely
against business like you know her
arguments I'm like well I'm young and we
head to that I don't worry when we get
to that later
yeah and that's that blew my mind
because I thought this is last we were
going to hear that and I'm like oh there
was payoff for this a number of episodes
later well done and yet no there is
there is a part of me I mean again they
didn't go into it a Man of Steel but
there is a part of me that likes those
times where it's like you gotta make
that show evil I'm never gonna kill I
never gonna you know it's not always
wise to say David never because you
could be put in situation were you doing
to do but with man you swore you would
never do talk about the neck break yeah
as they never talked about yeah my my
name added ah my problem with that is
not that he would do that I've never had
an issue my promise just like he's
probably inadvertently killed like
10,000 people already on that giant
fight and obviously like but this one
family of idiots I won't let you do it I
might really like this out of everything
like it's the way was executed was
stupid it might be an interesting idea
it did it right it's not at all that I
don't admire people that you know are
passive business and stuff like that and
say you know no I will not die I will
sooner die before I kill somebody watch
you should watch try no I mean it's like
i iose respect don't get me wrong uh
it's one of the things where it's like I
just don't know if that's my I always
wanted the last resort but it's life
it's an acting episode just like always
shit the can I have to examine the grey
zone now because yeah my instant
reaction was oh sweet yeah just share
our mall the end I'm like well but isn't
that like kind of monstrous and I'm
missing their looking key Nikki main
Stephen Stephen uh but then another part
of he's like yeah I guess the kid has a
point fucking Pollyanna no and she's not
wrong either you know it's one of those
things it's a tough zone and you think
they're just going to draw the line in
the sand that they get a little tricky
but pretty much that's a you choose the
side that they're like a lot of kids
shows doing them later on they really go
into some grades so an area that's like
oh man that's especially for kids you
know that's like that's like well yeah I
just like the design and have you ever
seen bismuth the like stone the no is it
very rainbow color yeah I they did and
it's like geometrically said like I
think it's like that I might have one
somewhere in rock collection I had from
when I was like 10 packed in a box
somewhere but uh yeah they're really
cool um and they I was kind of surprised
like oh you know I actually managed to
like make a person that I looked at and
I just like even before like you said
heard the neighbor like about that just
yeah like I knew what they were I knew
what they were doing
look the the actress who played or whose
oh a Dubai I think is how you say right
um she plays a crazy eyes on orange is
the new black and she is worthy of that
name this is an actress where you just
see here and even here it's like oh my
god this woman never for a millisecond
gives anything under a million percent
like everything is just so extreme and I
know intense in like just the utmost
effort a person can put it to her a see
but my favorite is like early on she
sounded kind of like Oprah to me I guess
same timbre to voice his way to likable
when she's been what she's pass out the
weapons though like I just want to be
like you get a weapon if you can imagine
you get away I see that she looks so
funny like there was like some point as
episode though where you were like oh
and I'm like what you couldn't figure
this out
in the beginning like what that she
don't forget what pointer was but yeah
that she's like you and you're like oh I
do you think no obviously she's evil
but no I remember no because it was some
point where I was just like dude no no
no it wasn't that I don't know I had no
weapons I like man I don't know that it
was rose that put her there and honestly
I still show woken up to that because II
hope that was the idea and I'm like
really yeah give it a like in the main
and you know there isn't one but nobody
seems so ok Alan Roth as you went to
like Oh son of a bitch I'm praying I
know there was something like I know
there's yeah yeah and there was
something about the way she was
upgrading those weapons that I just
almost done seems like this isn't feel
right like in your spheres now try bed
and your whip now is these like spiky
ball feels like he's a fucking rule yeah
like this kid show guys wonder why and
what I like they still use them to I was
like it with drama
so we're gonna imprison her but still
use their shit no you know and again
this actress I mean she she earns the
name creepy eyes in the show because she
just has you know you just look at the
cat you like and fast creepy eyes right
there but a person go crazy I pass her
and even without the visual like it
still comes through in that voice an
instant like an intense performance uh
every life she gives I'm you just where
she's like you know up to the mic like
this like grinding her teeth and stuff I
mean like veins popping out with like
every line you know she's just laughing
or talking softly uh so it's very very
well done I thought that was a pretty I
thought well it's gonna have do you
think this could have gotten across in
an 11 minute episode I think it could
have but it would have been a lot
clearer good honestly it's making me
realize that I really wish these were 22
minutes long less episode like it
depends on the episode I less some a
very thankful or show her no but okay
then see that's the problem like it's
hitting a point out where this series is
going on long if this was a shorter
series they're like
going to be only two seasons we're done
I probably wouldn't care but this is
going on long enough now that
particularly when you binge watch them
like this I'm like good good slot Slough
good Slough good slough and I'm like if
you cut out the fluff ones or just
incorporated them as slightly little
side things in otherwise good episodes I
know I feel like I remember the bismuth
episode like most of all because it was
in the 22 minute format where they could
take their time and do it and somebody
I'm not saying I want to bind together
chosen and they're 22 minutes long but
instead of 30 11 minute episodes do 15
22 minutes we go with something I'm
saying you know what something like
gravity falls you know they had their
fluff episodes too and the episodes that
came back more to them I don't feel like
they have ones that have both there are
never there is never time for side story
if you like a remember I always have to
be your one story I remember it easier
in a longer format I feel like if you
need to do something serious it plays
better in a longer format I feel like
this shorter format is more for
something like Aqua Teen Hunger Force or
you know like where it says like oh yeah
these shows are just goofy it's not like
I need to retain any information from
Aqua Teen Hunger Force except for I
should have gotten a snack there was a
long a story but but the same time you
brood which cannot be disassembled but
at the same time I feel like like you go
into a tenday Jun they do get right to
the point
which is kind of nice there's not that
much filler there's not that much fluff
but they have to have a couple episodes
that connect and it's like man that
would work better they all just if it's
a Gorn episode yeah like there's a
number of episodes that now that we've
got an actual plot going that I'm like
you could've cut that episode and then
we when I think there's a couple
characters that were like you could cut
I want way to do it is had to appoint
and maybe it's because we do have other
things to do it is a good show it is
when you get older your time does kind
of become more valuable and you are kind
of like okay I am sitting here watching
this can we really blah blah well I'm
not 10
today didn't don't watching cartoon for
ten-year-old so is one of those things
or it's like how do you do my friend it
is very strange but by know you're
talking about I don't know I'd be very
interested like I wouldn't I wait Lord
the longer I wish they would make this
way it would be interesting if they did
longer episode because there are other
good episodes after this but I still
remember the bismuth episode the most
because of that I feel like it is played
overall probably the best even though a
couple kinkle you know and you're right
because when I think of the other
episodes I think of seeds I think it
scenes I really remember I think a bad
episode I think of the whole episode of
whole giving me a tour yeah yeah it has
a beginning a middle and end and not to
say the others don't but they have to
rush them a little faster and you do in
mind the emotion a little bit more uh I
think they could play around them or
maybe they have I mail you're so we're
season why I probably get a whole bunch
of shit about how dare you uh know I
even though even though at times is no
opinion even at times I was even kind of
saying like you know case it's almost
feels like it's going on a little I mean
is longer by my head is feeling a little
long it still feels like it's setting up
the payoff you know and it is real or
enough it are things that are too short
it's almost exactly the same as when
things are too long it just I'm not
going to say it's boring but it's just
when the pay it's just the pacings off
hmm and you just don't retain it easier
you kind of Zone in and out and when I
met you when you marathoner which it has
how they're showing a lot of time
they're doing these Steven bombs the
Steven bomb yeah I just imagine like
this atom bomb with like that even space
on it is this is it's just a giant
mustard clown with like is Facebook okay
so talk about that more than up uh uh
theta this is the one where they go to
Jasper's birthplace amethyst kind of
gets her rematch realizes Peppa huh I
said I just love how freakin arrogant uh
prepared I heard that is yeah I'd like
that I mean look at this place
shit oh and then you see the freaking
jazz for one thing yeah but you know it
still like that we go ahead do it up
like it but uh like okay well glass but
but you know what if you go all the way
back and see it it's just like you can
almost hear her say like oh shit yeah no
I like them I was a lot of that well
it's a great build-up to the villa no
we're already afraid of you know of like
oh but there's got to be a blog not
leather Gabby play no I really mercy no
like that I really never wanted just
like a swear word jizz in there just
which it goes way back yeah but if you
go all the way to the maggot total yes
yeah like something yeah yeah it'd be
great a kid show um and again I mean we
get the lesson but it's done well when
they fused together and it's not about a
prize and I love their fusion and how
men have yeah that now is really two
arms and the oh and like I was it like
we're watching the middle of it I'm just
like Esther ever been like a street
fighting game or a Mortal Kombat style
game x-men like Capcom like you with a
Capcom fighting games where they've had
a yo-yo as a weapon yeah yeah very cool
there needs to be after watching this up
like it would be amazing to do special
moves with a yo-yo if you also to maybe
that you like it like the character was
like stupid extra super sick powerful or
something like way more than the
character should be so it's like Marvel
Squirrel Girl were it's like just
ridiculous yeah like an idiot character
with a yo-yo like has all these insane
powers I guess but wait of Super Smash
Brothers was it miss and yet has a
little bit yeah but yeah here like a bad
okay yeah I don't that like the main
villain sign that oh my oh yeah like
you're like with the yo-yo and doing all
the yo-yo tricks I like what they do
here I know that games we can use the
yo-yo of the weapon but I feel like a
great to it the width or a writer it's
like oh it's like when Simon Belmont
gets the fire we yeah so I thought that
was really good with crazy in peridot
again
she's always great and then we have
earthlings um actually this one I have
to remind myself limit contact even fuse
into smoky hallways oh wait then what
was oh oh you know what you are no no
this is exactly what we were talking
about okay so betta and Earthlings were
actually two episodes back-to-back Beto
was just setting up and then loving what
they did with the place yeah baby I we
can go quick they show off the barn it's
lapis and yeah peridot they show up what
they've done and then amethyst is still
in bitch mode me do it
gesturing with just but again if these
two were together if it was one long
episode and what you're right will that
work better I guess I can't use it for
one long and when you come don't man
it's one episode you don't off with the
barn and then move on and though I'm
sure there's like yeah you know my
favorite thing I do remember first off
what they did with the barn is awesome
but then when I go and do like their art
which they called something else which
is kind of me like a number what they
yell I see they have it here more even
meet Mort yeah me more those keep it I
love the one that's the TV and just like
I'm trapped I'm trapped I'm trapped oh
is this because you were trapped in that
mirror for someone I just like that show
and I know I love edgy you know the one
character I thought would I don't know
maybe they'll do more in the future but
the one I kind of felt like man there's
like real possibilities with that
character ahead yeah and you kind of got
I can't forget you even there even when
they're inviting dishes like snots I
don't know no thanks I knows we were
there just like fly us in no like okay
like no I don't know if this is like
actually really nah you're just kind of
why what it is you know that they had
built her up with she's got an
interesting character design a great a
filter up a great bag so they built her
up with such mystery that you thought
this was an arc that was going to go
somewhere much longer and not just fall
back on and then I'm just gonna live
with peridot like I thought they'd still
be doing stuff with lapis yeah but bite
as a my story arc yeah I feel like she
you know she has a wings fly way you
know like I feel like
madness I feel like we've done what you
know can be done with her but maybe not
maybe they're saving up for something
else but until then she's just kind of
you know I'm not doing that much that
was data and then one average yeah it
was earthlings with the big fight and
like we talked about with the fusion
between Stephen Bennett
probably marathon us there was a great
line in there though it's the shit now
maybe we'll come back to it well yeah
there there was a line about something
just like it's not about the pay it's
not about the past it's what you want to
be that was not about where you came
from
well not about where you came from its
where you want to be that is an amazing
line and strange enough that's actually
not the one I pick it up there no there
was some there's someone a great moment
and I can't remember it well we got two
more here to me when we talk about we
can come back to it all right so the
second alas one season is back to the
moon well you don't love the Rubies III
want it I am a lot to--and change too
that's what I love about this episode
completely it starts out very light very
funny out with you I love these the
rubies are like the minions it's they
have a right character yeah they're now
perfect in these little bite-sized
nuggets yeah like you know we were
saying like I saw the minions movie
finally I'm like it's fine like it's
alright but I'm just like yeah I do
prefer them in the background and the
same with the rubies it's like just
these little nuggets like I'm like I
could I could what I just love episodes
with the rubies it huh yes play that
stupid game yeah I mean and all their
different personalities and everything
even though they all look alike them
like just the rubies a different place
that's it they all have these very
distinct personalities where when you
look at them you know which one is which
I love that uh but yeah so they want to
is they think amethyst is Jasper she
disguises herself as her and they go to
the moon and they find out this big
shock and be just this huge total what
the hell that Rose actually did shatter
it one of the big powerful diamonds is a
pink diamond and this is like a big
thing Steven said you
no no we find out that Rose put business
away because of it help Stephen bismuth
away because of that I my jaw dropped
and I was like holy shit
pay off for that business SS I thought
they were just going to leave it there
just like Stevens like do like a rose -
yeah like a little Gary student right
and then they bottle business up I'm
like the end and we're never going to
return to it but when he finds out it's
like oh yeah no totally shattered like
you could just like and I love the
reaction pearl I think garnet like like
oh shit like didn't want Steven to know
that all the reactions are great because
amethyst has to stay as Jasper she can't
show anything and I think artists look
surprised by great whoa it's a great man
Meryl it's just you know I like that
because that's that's something about
pacifistic characters again you should
see try again this is what made Trigon
work when you get pacifistic characters
a lot of times it's there to perfect
no I would just do this over the pass
they don't have to really face either
the consequences of their actions or
faiths
sometimes a moment where they're just
like oh wow I have to question my own
beliefs and then this one like that was
a moment where Steven had to question
just like wow I put my life and soul on
the line to say this was wrong and it
turns out my mother was also kind of me
freaking shattered somebody like I did I
was like well and he wants to do that in
the show I'm like good job no he's going
off of the philosophy that she had not
yeah and that was her because that's
where my mom would do it like yeah your
mom didn't do that not so perfect after
all just like that home after such an
intense episode around that with
business just what a great great reveal
and it's done by characters that are not
threatening they're the little rubies
they're the most you know oh this is the
light episode this is all they have to
pretend to be someone they're not like
wow that happens sometimes we will find
out things about your friends or family
secrets or something and it's given away
in the most innocuous way not like some
evil
haha you'll find something out almost by
accident just be like oh like those
little surprises keep you on your toes
and it's still like oh like I didn't
know that was going to happen so you
don't always go in like oh it's this
episode it's this kind of it can still
really shock you uh and yet it's a good
it's a good dilemma and I think it's
something it's something good to start
kids off early honestly to like really
get them thinking about this that even
your whole philosophy and your thoughts
and everything can change and can be
challenged in to a point where you're
not always going to come out you know
with the philosophy you thought or maybe
you still have that philosophy but you
don't always follow it in sometimes it's
for a good reason or is it I mean
they're good questions and they don't
have solid a kids need darkness that was
the lesson of Don Bluth and the eighties
III do like this show for doing things I
did okay hello weird when Steven at the
very end thinks I'm like oh well thanks
for telling me I'm what they really did
until they got pushed into it because
someone else are dealing with well that
well that comes to the next episode
which I do now which is bubbled which is
kind of like the
2001 I really thought of gravity I was
thinking out I thought I really thought
for it's like he's in that bubble and
he's just in this like cocoon and I bomb
whatever in second he was going to wake
up and be in a bed and there's like the
model is at the end or something with a
crystal gem on he's like so he's he's
floating in a bubble one of the rubies
is there no driver just dunk fine that
maybe we'll just spend the rest of the
trip of silence I was like in an edgy
artistic move the next 15 minutes are
total so I ended season um okay so we'll
get to that soon about where we feel
this should've ended um but so she stuck
with Steven he gets her inside the
bubble and you know she gets damaged and
and he heals her and she finds out that
this is technically rose and even though
he heals her you could argue even kind
of saved her life she still tries to
kill him and he
has to let her go in space again yeah
very orbit very similar to the thing I
listed story it's the scorpion and
something wrong I think the Frog a
scorpion the frogs or it's just look at
the time
holy I'm your only way out yeah it was
like it's in my nature I feel I feel
like with the rubies that is almost a
case like it's just in their nature to
be like that well that's my doubt no
definitely that um say so she screws
herself over and that I thought it was
like dark I'm like what's way bye-bye
yeah we don't know what happened to her
after this whole story ends like 7
million years in the future and she's
just still in space like and this sucks
you know cat makes me wonder this bromby
fact is I kind of doesn't connect at all
but in Wonder Woman where that woman
whose dress she stole whatever that was
led she killed her
there's some corpse in them yeah I mean
or even she knocked her out like it was
cold like is there just this like cold
woman that's just like freezing to death
naked somewhere I mean it's actually
kind of a terrifying she walks up naked
in front of two Nazi soldiers guten
abend
um but anyway okay just finally get
another was that I don't know I just I
you suddenly thought of it because it
made me think of that just oh my god
it's like this thing you can't forget
about it like that's actually I thought
of the thing I thought the thing I
thought the thing it was a somewhere in
that episode Stephen has this whole like
speech and he's just talking about like
yes Jasper's perfect but we're both
imperfect and that was just a theme like
I can't remember what they said exact
boobs me but I just like this idea that
these are the two like kind of screw-ups
and he said something like and were the
only ones like this you know cuz
amethyst with you know everyone like
that but but I like my men like this and
she may seem perfect and like we may be
imperfect but there it was very cute I'm
just like oh it's like these these two
kind of runt kids like are just like you
know what we deserve a shot at this to
like you know we're going to do this we
may be imperfect but that's what makes
us special and like I just like that
whole see it I can't remember the lines
they use their you
weakness to win the day just like
Jasper's our uniqueness - oh so I love
that bit that was my favorite part of
that episode but anyway so that's
centers of puzzled so we're at the end
of this episode throws her out into
space he's in the bubble just you know
curled up in a ball
backs up shows the universe Christ we
wish it ended there yes
it's like I'm like I'm rolling friend
cut embassy and in the year and then the
ship came in and I'm like and fuck you
know and that would have it sound a bit
like the Empire Strikes Back for like
kids watching cartoon network yeah what
what well what a cliffhanger and you
know you could have had her you know
they could have gotten him the hug cries
and why didn't you tell me going back to
earth and stuff that could have been an
episode like just a bad about what
happened with her but they have and I
have how much did what do you think oh
no no do you think they originally want
to end it there and then like the studio
or somebody said no no you got and the
focus groups are saying gain a you know
unlikely because I feel it would have
been the opposite I feel like they
usually take a lot risk I feel I feel
like they would have thought who this
will make sure people watch next season
I know but I'm at weddings about Tom I
don't know if this we even was like
because like it seems like every time we
watched it sometimes like it's just
arbitrary like was this truly the end of
it going to the list not an idiot that
was the end of the see if there was
supposed to be a chunk of time after
this episode yeah they messed up like I
really don't know they should have
stopped with him being lost in space and
that has been fine but maybe they were
too worried that the series is gonna get
cancelled a leg up we can do that a bit
sooner
Holly here and the series ends right
there Stephen floating in space is the
other Ruby flooding elsewhere nobody
knows what happens that would be amazing
and well what am i right let's do we got
to write our own cartoons yeah so what
one of my favorite cliffhangers of all
time
it was never resolved
they was / it is the biggest fuck you it
was uh the sonic no no Arizona what
about that no but they thought Amanda
dust man what I want to go where they
purposefully made it on the biggest
cliffhanger like of all time and they
never answered it and it's just that to
be considered to be continued as idyllic
question mark as I never I think they do
that was the last season they just
purposefully left it on that and it was
really serious and it was like holy
smokes you got balls I mean that would
just piss off so many people you but I
was got pissed off but I'm like man I
gotta give credit that's just so Foley
uh so when it's all said and done I've
got to admire you ball well maybe uh so
yeah that's our Steven bomb here I don't
know when we can get to the neck so
we're going to try and find since I just
find a day where we can just get a
remote through a whole season yeah just
get through a season um I don't know
when that is I'm hoping within a month
but I mean fingers crossed like I said I
mean we can't we can't promise the what
the summers out no matter what I thought
yeah I feel like we can find a day to do
that um so uh yep guys I hope you
enjoyed that but that's just how we're
going to do is look at me yes still guys
doing it's still really interesting and
again I'm just so glad I'm glad to kid
show I'm glad this is the show the kids
are getting and it's a big hit and
adults are into it too and it's
challenging its creative as imaginative
and yeah it's really cool to see it
still going at that so uh that's about
it we'll see you in another half a year
no I won't see you before that oh there
it is there tonight here I am talking to
myself that that's cam that's even yeah
that's just
just turn off wait we haven't done this
for a while will you expect
turn it off okay now no tomorrow yes now
go to my wake it down at all turn it off